fieback zu haben macht wirklich keinen
großen spaß und erst recht nicht wenn
man mit voller konzentration am start
sein muss sowie die astronautin
astronauten in der schwerelosigkeit
jetzt sagt eine neue studie aber dass
sie im weltraum genau mit diesem problem
zu kämpfen haben sie laufen regelrecht
heiß wie gesundheitsgefährdend das
ständige weltraum fieber wirklich ist
und warum diese erkenntnis auch einen
rückschlag für zukünftige marsmissionen
bedeuten könnte
jetzt sind klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen ja immer mal wieder
gibt es ja studien die davor warnen dass
die raumfahrt tatsächlich
gesundheitliche risiken für den
menschlichen organismus mit sich bringt
einige studien der vergangenheit
beispielsweise legt nahe dass die
sehkraft im all beeinträchtigt werden
kann wahrscheinlich wohl ausgelöst durch
die minimale schwerkraft dort jetzt
kommt ein neuer punkt dazu weltraum
fieber eigentlich ja erst einmal
seltsamen alle ist es ja alles andere
als warm
umso wärmer dafür aber die körper der
astronauten astronauten das sagt jetzt
eine neue studie die in der
fachzeitschrift scientific reports
veröffentlicht worden ist beteiligt
waren unter anderem auch wissenschaftler
und wissenschaftlerinnen der charité in
berlin ergebnis ganz konkret die
körpertemperatur von astronauten den
astronauten liegt die zahl zustand rund
ein grad über dem normalwert der hier
auf der erde gilt der irdische wert
liegt bei 37 grad dieses ergebnis stammt
von messungen an elf astronauten
astronauten jeweils sechs monate auf der
iss verbracht haben die dafür
verwendeten stirn sensoren messen die
sogenannte kerntemperatur also die
temperatur die die inneren organe und
das gehirn haben doch die temperatur der
probandinnen und probanden stieg nicht
automatisch an als sie dem weltraum
erreicht hatten sondern nach angaben der
neuen studie im laufe der zeit konkret
wurden die körper etwa zweieinhalb
monate lang immer wärmer dann etwa
pendelte sich die temperatur bei rund 38
grad ein und das könnte fatale folgen
haben sagt das forschungsteam dazu
später mehr
denn es kommt noch krasser die messungen
zeigen dass die körpertemperatur der
astronautinnen astronauten sogar oft auf
mehr als 40 grad ansteigt also das ist
ziemlich gefährlich schon hier auf der
erde sollte man es möglichst vermeiden
seine körpertemperatur bei schwerer
arbeit nicht ständig über 38 grad
steigen soll das sind doch die probanden
knacken regelmäßig die 40 grad und zwar
dann wenn sie trainieren
das problem dabei sport gehört zum
alltag im weltraum denn bei langen
aufenthalten muss das team trainiert und
fit bleiben als studie passt das mit
erzählung von astronauten und
astronauten bei allen die immer wieder
mal von unwohlsein und hitzestress
berichteten ja vor allem beim training
ja und das bedeutet abgesehen davon dass
die eigene gesundheit ziemlich
angegriffen wird ja ist man weder
körperlich noch geistig zurechnungsfähig
jedenfalls sich komplett man trifft
vielleicht andere entscheidungen also
man es mit einem klaren kopf tun würde
eine echte gefahr für die mission also
die neue studie geht davon aus dass
dieses ständige weltraum fieber von den
umständen dort herbeigeführt wird der
körper kann in der schwerelosigkeit nur
schwer seine überschüssige hitze los
werden selbst wenn dieser der schweiß
der verdampft weniger als auf der erde
und somit wird die hitze schlechter
abtransportiert und genau das ist auch
die erklärung dafür warum der
menschliche organismus beim sport also
besonders viel schweiß steht im weltraum
so schnell überhitzt weltraumflüge die
sich über einen langen zeitraum
erstrecken wie zum beispiel richtung
mars können dadurch deutlich erschwert
werden das heißt es in der studie
dieses weltraum fifa hat potenzielle
auswirkungen auf langfristige
weltraumflüge in bezug auf die
gesundheit das wohlbefinden und auch auf
körperliche und kognitive leistungen ja
das wäre starker tobak lange missionen
wie eben die zum mars würden damit
infrage gestellt ja wir sehen mal weiter
wie es was ich da ergibt bei diesen
untersuchungen ihr kein video zu diesem
thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt drückt man hier aber
aufs auge und vergesst nicht dem genau
auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch
immer über neue videos informiert wie
geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
1000 raketen zu mars ja ansonsten bis
dann bleibt da